[Musique]
les essentiels du
Sénat réformer l'accès aux données de
connexion dans l'enquête
pénale les données de connexion ou
métadonnées sont les traces techniques
laissées sur un réseau par un terminal
ces données peuvent par exemple révéler
les déplacement d'une personne ses
interactions numériques ou téléphoniques
avec des tiers ou la liste des sites
internet n qu'elle a visité d'où leur
rôle majeur dans les enquêtes pénales en
2022 près de 3 millions de données de
connion ont fait l'objet d'une
réquisition ce nombre est en Haus
tendentielle de 10 % par an depuis 2017
en France une plateforme nationale des
interceptions judiciaires offre aux
enquêteurs un accès aux données de
connexion mais la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne a progressivement
remis en cause la vaste utilisation de
ces données en prohibant leur conser
tion généralisé à des fins pénales et en
limitant leur utilisation par les
enquêteurs aux infractions relevant de
la criminalité dite grave de plus la
jurisprudence européenne a imposé avant
tout accès à ces données un contrôle
préalable par une autorité indépendante
ou une juridiction c'est dans ce
contexte que la commission des lois a
créé en février 2023 une mission
d'information sur l'usage des données de
connexion dans l'enquête pénale au terme
de leurs travaux les rapporteurs AG
Canayer et Philippe boncarer constatent
que les évolutions législatives n'ont
pas suffi à mettre notre droit national
en conformité avec la jurisprudence
européenne en raison notamment du
maintien d'une conservation générale et
indifférenciée des données de connexion
et d'un accès qui n'est pas toujours
soumis à un contrôle préalable et
indépendant il formule 16
recommandations tout d'abord les
rapporteurs appellent le gouvernement à
assumer une position forte dans les
négociations européennes en faisant du
sujet des données de connexion une
priorit pour la France il l'invite en
particulier à œuvrer pour
l'aboutissement rapide de l'examen du
règlement e-privacy 2 la mission
recommande aussi de mieux tirer profit
des flexibilités de la jurisprudence
européenne qui offre malgré tout
certaines souplesses en matière de
conservation et d'accès aux données
d'identification notamment dans le cadre
des infractions commises en ligne face
au sentiment d'insécurité juridique des
acteurs de l'enquête pénale les
rapporteurs considèrent qu'il revient au
législateur d' venir la loi devra ainsi
rappeler que le contrôle préalable et
indépendant de l'accès aux métadonnées
n'est exigé par la Cour de justice que
pour les données de trafic et de
localisation un accès autorisé par le
parquet pour les données
d'identification qui constitue une
moindre atteinte à la vie privée pourra
donc être maintenue la mission propose
de confier le contrôle des données de
trafic et de localisation au juges des
libertés et de la
détention selon elle le gouvernement
doit mener une réflexion sur les outils
informatique à développer pour permettre
un contrôle
pragmatique pour en savoir plus
consultez le site Internet du
Sénat